by now you may have heard about area
launched in 2012 and backed by Barry
Diller it allows you to watch broadcast
TV over the internet but is area legal
here's how it works
in 13 cities so far Arielle has created
antenna farms warehouses full of dime
size than tenants
these work much like the rabbit ears you
would attach to your television at home
they receive free over-the-air signals
from broadcasters like ABC CBS NBC and
Fox aerial takes that signal and resends
it to subscribers via the Internet you
can then watch live TV on your computer
tablet and smartphone area will even let
you record shows to the cloud for later
viewing
the service costs eight or twelve
dollars a month but here's where it gets
sticky pre Aereo there were three ways
to watch broadcast television you can
bolt an antenna to your roof or TV and
get it for free you could pay a cable
company for a box or you can pay a
satellite company for a dish while
you're paying cable and satellite
companies they're paying broadcasters so
they can retransmit their programming to
the tune of about four billion dollars a
year but you know how much Aereo pays
broadcast networks zilch ariel argues
that it's pulling down the same free
signal anyone can get with their own
antenna the fact that the antennas
happen to be in a warehouse and not on
subscribers rooves they say shouldn't
matter
broadcasters say this is bummer and that
area is no different than a cable
company in March of 2012 they sued Aereo
for violating copyright law the
broadcaster's lawsuit hangs on one thing
whether or not area's retransmission is
considered a public performance it is
Aereo is infringing because they haven't
paid for the programming like cable
companies do
if the court decides aerial service is
just a lot of private performances the
Wonder for each subscriber it wouldn't
be an infringement and Ariel wouldn't
need to pay the broadcaster's so far
both the lower and appellate courts have
sided with area
now it's up for the Supreme Court to
decide arguments will be in April and
there will be a ruling by July